welcome to exploring computing
today's video is digital music
part three compress that music as i
suggested in the last video
even though cd audio allows us to store
music
digitally that's not actually what most
of you are listening to
now if the standards were developed
right now
it's possible we just stick with cd
audio but
because the internet music standards
were actually developed 20 years ago
back when your parents were in college
it turns out that there are some issues
with cd audio
the problem with cd audio is that cd
audio takes up a lot of space
how much space does it take well let's
take a look here suppose we have a five
minute song
and we're trying to send this through
the internet
let's say for example your parents are
in a band there's this new music called
punk rock
they create this great punk rock
five-minute song and they want to send
it home to their little brother or
little sister
so what they're going to do is they're
going to go ahead and record that
five-minute song
convert it to digital using the
techniques we just talked about a little
bit earlier
and then the question is how large is
that file well let's go ahead and do the
math here
five minutes times 60 seconds per minute
times 44
100 samples per second times two
channels one for the left and the right
speaker so remember we always have to
double that if we've got two
two channels um times 16 bits per sample
and so it turns out if we calculated
this all out it takes about 50 and a
half megabytes
now that doesn't sound horrible by
today's standards but
again going back to 20 years ago when
your parents were in college
they're going to send that through the
internet to their little brother or
little sister at home
and the question is how long is your
little brother or little sister going to
take to download
that brand new five minute punk rock
song well
it turns out it's going to take about
five hours
and the other little piece of
information that you may be missing
is that the telephone back then
was used for both the internet and for
voice
and you had to choose which one you were
using it for so for five hours
well the little brother or little sister
is downloading that
five minute song nobody else can use the
telephone
so clearly this is a problem and so the
solution
is mp3 files and we're actually going to
be talking about
mp3 files in this video but i do want to
mention that
there are several other formats that are
very closely related so
you know if you're listening to music on
an apple device that you bought from
itunes that's probably going to use aac
and if you're possibly listening on a
windows device
you might be using wma both the aac
and the wma standard follow very closely
on mp3 so
almost everything i'm talking about here
with mp3 is going to be very similar
in terms of the other audio formats that
you might be using
there is a newer format that's quite
different
that doesn't bother doing as much
compression and we'll talk about that in
the very last video of this series
okay so we've got a problem which is
that our music
is taking up too much space we need to
reduce the amount of space it takes so
that we can transfer these files around
on the internet in a reasonable amount
of time so what are we going to do
well what we're going to do is we're
going to
perform a number of different steps to
reduce the amount of space
this audio file takes the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to
perform a fast fourier transform
i don't want to go into the mathematical
details on this to be honest
uh i didn't like doing fast fourier
transforms in college and that's one of
the reasons why i stopped being
electrical engineer i'm now a computer
scientist but
the basic idea behind a fast fourier
transform is
any sound wave or any wave for that
matter can be broken down into
constituent parts where each of the
parts is
a single frequency so you know we might
have
uh a song playing and we might be able
to break that
song down into oh here's a 60 hertz wave
here's a 80 hertz wave here's 120 hertz
wave
you know they all have different
amplitudes but when they all combine
together
that's what we're actually listening to
so we're going to go ahead and perform
this fast fourier transform and
determine what the
individual constituent frequencies are
now what we're going to do is we're
going to use something called
psychoacoustics to eliminate some of
these frequencies so psychoacoustics is
the science of how humans actually
listen to sounds so it turns out there's
a bunch of sounds we just don't hear
most notably we probably all know that
there are certain frequencies that
are just too high pitched for us to hear
so for example a dog whistle works
because
when you blow a dog whistle there's a
very high pitched
high frequency sound that comes out of
it and the dogs can all hear it
but the humans can't because it's too
high for humans to hear
there's also other tricks that we can
use to eliminate certain
sounds from our information so for
example if there's a
loud sound and then there's a much
softer sound that's in a nearby
frequency humans just will completely
ignore the softer sound so
what we're going to do is we're going to
use our psychoacoustics and we're going
to start tossing out part of this music
now one thing to note here is we are
losing information so
previously when we talked about
compressing images we talked about
compressing using the jpeg technique we
talked about compressing using the png
technique remember the png technique was
lossless
no information was lost we were able to
reduce the amount of space those files
took
but we were able to completely reproduce
the bitmap image that we started with
in contrast the jpegs lose information
and the mp3s are going to work similarly
so one way of thinking about it is
suppose i take beethoven's fifth
the original cd audio sound and i
perform the psychoacoustic analysis on
it
if i perform this well hopefully the
music will sound exactly the same to me
but think about my poor dog here my
dog's listening to the original cd
quality sound
there's these beautiful high frequency
tones
and i don't hear any of that so i go
ahead and toss them out i replayed the
music
in its new mp3 format and my dog is like
what did you do what happened to all
those beautiful high frequency notes
they're all gone
all right so we are losing information
here we're not done yet though there's
another step we need to take
and that's called performing a huffman
encoding
now i don't want to go into the details
on this but the basic idea here is that
a hyphen coding looks for sequences
which
appear frequently and sequences that
don't appear very frequently what it's
going to do is it's going to store
the sequences which appear frequently in
less space than the sequences that
appear infrequently
i like to show this by analogy so many
of you may be familiar with
at least the concept of morse code and
so probably the most famous mars code
message is sos for save our ship so you
can imagine the titanic's there
the titanic's hit an iceberg and it's
sinking and they're transmitting this
message using morse code
while rose and jack are freezing out in
the water and so the message is
sos save our ship and the famous symbol
for sos in morse code is dot dot dot
which stands for s
dash dash dash which stands for o and
dot dot dot which stands for s so they'd
be transcending dot dot dot
dash dash dot dot and then they would
just repeat that
so how is this relevant to our
discussion well it turns out in morse
code
we can obviously transmit all the
different letters but the amount of
space it takes to transmit a letter
varies depending upon the frequency of
the letter so the letter e
that's a super common letter and so
we're going to transmit e just with a
single
dot and a that's pretty common too so
we're going to transmit an a by a dot
dash in contrast to q that doesn't show
up very often so we're going to transmit
that in a
dash dash dot dash and so a q will take
four times as much space or take four
times as long to transmit as an e
and so the huffman encoding is going to
do something very similar with our music
here
okay so we performed our psychoacoustic
analysis we've done our half-minute
coding
we have a new version of our song it's
stored in this mp3 format
let's take a quick look at how much
space the mp3 is going to take as
opposed to the
as opposed to the original cd audio the
first thing we need to
remember is that mp3 is a lossy format
just like jpeg and just like jpeg the
amount of loss can be set
so i can decide i really want this to
sound as close to pristine as possible
or i can decide
i'm going to be listening to this in the
gym so i really don't care
how good the quality is it's going to be
a very noisy listening environment
anyway
so some common settings are 128
kilobytes per second and 192 kilobits
per second there are some others that
you can use as well
let's assume that we are using our 128
kilobits per second we've got our five
minute song
60 seconds per minute kilobits per
second
that gives us 38 400 kilobits total for
a five minute song
and then i need to divide that by eight
bits per byte and that's going to give
us four and a half megabytes now
remember
our original cd audio song was 50.47
megabytes
we're able to listen to the exact same
music in four and a half megabytes
by converting it to an mp3 so you can
see we've saved a
huge amount of space at a potential loss
in quality
where again we have at least some
control over the quality loss
in the next video i want to explicitly
look at the relationship between analog
and digital this is something we've been
kind of dancing around with
all throughout last lecture and this
lecture and it's a really key topic so i
want to spend some time
explicitly looking at it